if you have a severe problem with the
aortic valve in your heart and you can't
have open-heart surgery your doctor may
recommend a transcatheter aortic valve
implantation
your aortic valve is one of the four
valves in your heart it lies between
your left ventricle or lower left
chamber and the large blood vessel
supplying oxygen-rich blood to your body
called the aorta when your left
ventricle contracts during each
heartbeat it pushes blood through three
flexible cup-like leaflets that make up
your aortic valve when your left
ventricle relaxes your aortic valve
closes to prevent blood from flowing
back into your left ventricle
as you get older your aortic valve may
develop deposits of calcium that cause
your leaflets to get thicker and less
flexible in this condition your leaflets
may not open fully this condition called
calcific a or tech valve stenosis
creates a narrowed opening that reduces
the amount of blood flowing into your
aorta and out to your body the narrowed
valve opening strains your heart because
it has to pump harder to move enough
oxygen-rich blood to your body
at the beginning of your procedure your
doctor will make a small incision in
your groin after creating an opening in
a blood vessel called the femoral artery
your doctor will insert a flexible tube
called an introducer sheath
through the sheath your doctor will
insert a flexible guide wire into your
femoral artery the guide wire will be
passed through your femoral artery
all the way up to your aorta then the
guide wire will be pushed through the
opening in your aortic valve and into
your left ventricle your doctor will use
the guide wire to pass a flexible tube
called a catheter through your aortic
valve
a balloon on the tip of the catheter
will be inflated to widen the opening in
your aortic valve and push the valve
leaflets to the sides after deflating
the balloon your doctor will remove the
catheter the replacement valve consists
of a tissue valve surrounded by a wire
mesh called a stent the replacement
valve will be compressed and placed on
the tip of another catheter this
catheter will be inserted through your
aortic valve when the catheter reaches
the opening in your aortic valve your
surgeon will inflate a balloon
underneath the replacement valve to
expand it and the stent after placement
of the new aortic valve your surgeon
will deflate the balloon
the stent will support and secure the
replacement valve in place the catheter
and guide wire will be removed
at the end of your procedure the
introducer sheath in your groin will be
removed your skin incision will be
closed with stitches you will have
another incision on the other side of
your groin through which instruments
were inserted to monitor your heart
during the procedure
this skin incision will be closed in a
similar manner